[Music]
hi whistle aditya and this week i'm
gonna be interviewing Samuel regarding
his financial freedom challenge what it
is why is he doing it and really digging
deep into exactly what's gonna be going
on so thank you very much Samuel for
joining us on your own show thanks for
letting me there guess the my own show
man so tell us first of all what is the
financial freedom challenge well I'll
have a have done a video in the past
asain what it is but it's basically
where I am going to start from scratch
and the challenge is to become
financially free whatever again I don't
know nothing with an alias name yeah we
can we find out what the name is or is
that secret the moment look I'm not
gonna say what my name is certainly not
yet okay at some point it'll be revealed
I do know what the name is but I don't
know where I'm going to be yet and I'm
not allowed to do business with anyone
that I've previously met before so you
start out from scratch yeah new area new
name you know contact yeah okay so I
suppose it begs the obvious question why
are you putting yourself through this
well I guess the questions of why I'm
doing it how long I think it's gonna
take me what I'm gonna do how I'm going
to do it I mean what I'm doing it it's
for a few reasons the main reason is
because I want to really bust the myths
and break any excuses that it is not
possible okay so it's easy for people to
say to me
oh now you've got money and you've got
your reputation and you've got this and
you've got that it's easy for you now
but for me they say it's type of fun I'm
living in this area or I haven't got any
money or I've got bad credit or whatever
so uh I basically the rules of the
challenge which you know in another
video which is in the description but
the rules to the challenge is giving me
all the worst possible starting points
yeah do not feel in a way that you've
already done this challenge from a very
bad starting point I
17 year old kid yeah you know you know
your story the crash course 10 years ago
yeah exactly so do you not feel like
you've already achieved and why you put
yourself cuz it's hard right yeah why
are you putting yourself through it
again when it's something that you've
already done before again a few reasons
I did it before but that was then this
is now
and that was 10 years ago why not first
started okay so things changed and and
again people say oh it was easier in
those days you could buy and refinance
the same day but whatever even though I
think it was easier in those days I
think it's easier in these days it's my
opinion so I think also last time it
took me like four years yeah it took me
a long time so this could be a very long
documentary what I'm going to document
it but it definitely worked 84 years it
won't even take me you know I'll do I'll
do this it'll be weeks I'm pretty
confident so how are you gonna document
it exactly okay so I'm gonna have
obviously my my phone with me so I'm
gonna probably as I go along
I'll be keeping people up to post it to
some degree yeah are we maybe taking
pictures I'll be doing some some video
of myself but I'm gonna have a freelance
videographer who's going to be a fly on
the wall and he's going to put together
an official documentary from a third
party floor on the wall perspective of
exactly what happened throughout the
whole time okay that's pretty excited
yeah so when what about the challenge so
I'm starting the challenge I'm starting
with nothing all over again I don't know
where I'm gonna be yet that's gonna be
on the 15 15th of November okay 15th of
November and when are we gonna be able
to watch this documentary and find out
okay so I'm gonna be vlogging and
sharing a little bit little bit on
YouTube but mostly is gonna be on the
Facebook group okay which is property
bestest with Samuel Leeds so I was
recommend going on there keeping on what
he's doing yeah as to be part of the
group there's a free group and I'm gonna
be probably just putting pictures and
stories and stuff as I go I'm hoping
really really really really really hope
it that I'll be able to complete the
challenge within six weeks
six weeks we're 15 for November hope you
till like Christmas Day okay because I
don't want to be I don't want to be out
on my own
in a farm implies on Christmas Day
foreign place well foreigners in unknown
to me okay because because literally and
in fact on this I'm gonna give up I'm
gonna let people on this video choose on
this video people a bit cheesy where I'm
gonna be wow
so I don't know where I'm gonna be but I
don't want to be somewhere where I have
properties already that rules out a lot
of places that Wow I mean I've got
properties in quite a few places but
I've got places in middle of bra
Bradford hole Oxford obviously all over
the Midlands Wales possibly parts of
Wales it leaves a lot of places open
still yeah okay so I hope no continue
somewhere really horrible no not
necessarily because if it's a cheap it's
a pros and cons think if I'm sent this
somewhere I don't want to start naming
places because I don't want a pot my
dears people's mind basically how I
think how we're going to having to do
this is if you're watching this guy's is
comment below the town or the city that
you want me to be in and any place that
gets mentioned more than what so if
someone says Wolverhampton they won't
say that because that's where I'm based
so that wouldn't be good if someone says
Wolverhampton it will be ignored if two
people say well perhaps it you know we
put in the Hat there it will be put into
a hat okay yeah if three people yeah so
that's kind of how we're gonna do it
right so question a minute and then
it'll be pulled out of a hat on random
all I will pull it out all that hat or
video myself doing it and it'll be
revealed and I'm gonna do that probably
the day before the 15th Wow you're not
literally gonna have no idea where you
don't have no idea I might even do it
the morning off it depends on what might
my videographer how he wants to play it
I might even wake up and just go right
I'm off to such a such a place nice and
then and then and then and then I have
got
a budget for a week to put in a hotel
how much is that budget so I can't I
can't spend more than a hundred panel
nine okay so it can't be a fancy hotel
yeah yeah okay and then the end of the
week if I've not made any of money I'm
done so your prediction is weeks so
let's say for example yeah that you go
out three weeks you found few deals that
would be incredible yeah and you say
right I now choose to stop
obviously normally a house will take
longer than a few weeks to actually
starts making you money so how are you
gonna track how much money good question
good question so I'm gonna I'm gonna
secure the deals find all the deals get
them all in the bag get the money coming
in and everything now my target is three
thousand pounds a month okay if I can
hit 3k a month and half of that needs to
be passive or residual income a
recurring ongoing income and then half
of it can be active income make sense
yeah three grand a month full property
income it's well yeah you couldn't just
go and get a job you know and they're
off this and your ass halfway there well
Wow I mean how could I get a job boy if
I got a job that's zero plus of income
so that's not really gonna know I mean
fee one and a half grand that isn't well
all I know is property income okay you
know so yeah it's clearly property
income once I've got that I'm then going
to have to prove that so we've got an
independent accountant property person
here I don't know that the official
title who's gonna go over the figures
and that's going to be someone
independent which will all be revealed
on the documentary I don't even know who
the person is what they are what they
are they're gonna go over the figures
yeah and they're gonna have to validate
that I have done it I'm also gonna have
a referee with me because the
videographer I really wanted to use neck
are neck Nick but we figured
it would be better to get someone
freelance yeah who doesn't work for me
and the freelance person that we've got
is a guy called yin and Yan is yeah he's
a follower of my stuff extremely excited
about the challenge and reached out to
me and said can i film it but he's going
to be very strict to make sure that it's
it's edited problems a stickler he's a
stickler it's going to be edited in a
true and accurate fashion so I have no
control over the I'm not they're going
to be editing it with Nick he's gonna be
doing that so it's very I've tried to
Simon Zoo she said that I basically set
myself up to fail completely
I mean song as if she was just looked at
the rules and stuff summer's eve anyone
doesn't notice these there is a
successful property investor who's a
millionaire he went through the rules
and just said III would rather you the
mail i I can't I just can't tell you I
think you've done is by announcing it
and by you know by talking about yeah
you've made cell phone burnable I told
people the dates if you secretly rented
it in the background and there it was
over the last two months exactly so then
then it's one thing yeah and now they'll
have done that many times that you know
you but you know yeah but I just don't
have for a challenge to myself doing
this before and succeeded yeah but I'm
just but I haven't been quite as a
strict yeah you're either too home for
example I mean like I've been in my
house yeah and I was observes you
contact yeah and I've got my staff to
help out with things mmm but you know
yourself better do better have fun
actually
as someone who obviously delegates quite
a lot yeah which also you are right now
do you think that the little things do
you think that that might throw you have
what yeah I mean one of the reasons I'm
doing this as well is because I think
that I want to I want to really keep
connective in my students and a lot of
students that come on the property
investors cross course and things like
that you know they're doing everything
they're working in a full-time job and
it might be that they won't do it if
they if they started all over again if
they said right not
sorry they started for the first time
and you said right I booked two weeks
holiday from my job and I'm gonna go
crazy they wouldn't have
they wouldn't have developers and this
and nine and loads of finances and
resources and staff used to put them
that they'd have to leave fits in and
post in layers and stuff they'd have to
physically do it themselves all the
things I just going to ask you if Cara's
answered it there is I know a couple
people have sort of said oh it's not
realistic because you should I do it I
have to fit it around a full times of
what you say on a stupid book to me so
yeah yeah but two weeks of holiday yeah
yeah there'll always be some people that
say you know all while it you know oh
it's easier for you still I mean even
with a bad leg and alias name no access
to a credit a zero bank account with one
week in a hotel they'll still be people
that will still find somehow reasons why
that is more privileged than their
situation of course because they're too
stupid yeah but the bottom line is I
don't know anyone that's ever done that
before my favorite the people that go I
want to say oh it's not fair because
you've got the knowledge yeah I mean
that's the point that's the point
I'm proving that with the right
knowledge and the right confidence with
the right knowledge and the right
confidence anyone can do this
yeah yeah that's really good so what are
the main strategies do you think you're
gonna go for what you know I don't even
know yet I don't even know yet they'll
probably be different to what I did ten
years ago and they'll also maybe even be
slightly different for some of the
things I do now you know now we're doing
you know we just buy put budgets and
purchase big HMOs and things like that I
must be a little bit more creative but
that's that's going to be revealed on
the documentary okay it's not gonna let
anything go I don't even know for sure
yet but yeah of course it will come out
so I'm raising fine
not going to be drawn on that though oh
come on okay okay cool
what do you think what you most scared
of I am that I am a little bit afraid I
must say I am very happy to make myself
vulnerable I always make myself
vulnerable I'm a little bit I am I have
good days and bad days and people say
all has the preparation go for the
challenge preparation I don't know where
I'm gonna be I don't know where I'm
gonna be I don't know one of the things
I know that you do never you making a
decision I know that you'll have done
this fool this challenge I'm arranged in
the same yeah I came up with best case
worst case likely case yeah what other
good question so whenever I do is you
know I'll always say what's the best
case situation what's the worst case
what's the likely case
okay so the best case is that'll be fine
actually free within a month I'll be
home by Christmas and and I would
inspire or inspire hundreds maybe
thousands of people and now think unlike
goodness if he can do it starting with
nothing can only conceit and doing that
and like you can see the strategies that
you uses I can do that
mm-hm and then those people that are in
boring jobs being treated badly with no
hope no time for that family don't think
it's possible yeah will be inspired and
awakened to realizing it as possible
and as a result of that more and more
people will then be able to take control
of their life take responsibility and
get better results that that that's the
best case that's a pretty good best case
Oh massive best case massive best case
and also that could happen on a massive
scale hopefully people will you know
share the video and they'll be
despondent that that but that's the best
case um worst case worst case is the
oldest fail worst case is that after a
week I won't have any money to pay for
more hotels I'll get kicked out of my
hotel I will be homeless and I'll have
to quit the challenge what point would
you quit
I'm not a quitter so take quite a lot
sleep on your car
I don't know I don't know I don't you
want to think about that because I'm
sure I'm going to have done the deal
within a week
I'm sure even whatever wherever you drop
me naked in it anywhere in the country
with nothing and I'm confident within a
week I'll get some cash again on record
and say I'm gonna be dropped off naked
no I won't be naked but your listeners
just haft whoa but in regards to worst
case worst case she's really here's the
thing worst case is all look stupid
worst case is pity's is it's all those
people wanting me to fail why does that
bother you well yeah I mean I hate I'm
human right I'm human so
failing and being humiliated and and
also just in myself because I'm
competitive with myself you know it will
be it will be very annoying and
embarrassing failure it will be however
I think even if I fail there'll be a
lesson in that
there'll be lessons in that cuz it it's
okay to fail would you say the likely
case then like the case is that one very
confident succeed likely case is all
succeed that's it so the same is best
case pretty much but best case is also
seed and it'll just go it will just grow
big and lots of people know about it and
lots of people will be inspired a lot of
people take action I guess that's not in
my control
yeah but worst case is all look stupid I
know you also normally put percentages
on stuff so what percentage did you say
chance and your opinion might fail I'm
probably gonna say I'm like probably 75%
that I'll succeed I can't be too
arrogant I regret saying one week I
should have said that I'll have some
people got the wrong man instead of
saying there's got one week just become
financially for it now I've got one week
before I get leaked from my hotel yeah
I'm good as long as it takes to become
financially free it could take a year in
my mind I'll be very upset
likely case I'll take lightly cases that
I'll do it but I it will run right on
until until the new year okay that would
be annoying but that's probably like the
case yeah but
gasps a month yes the documentary is
going to be coming out on Boxing Day
regardless of what happens and where
we're at there's going to be a
documentary coming out boxing though
sadly either you've quit you've
succeeded or this is where I've got to
so far yeah little bit there Matt and
that might be a part two of it but I
hope not the Boxing Day but boxing day
we'll know what's going on yeah well at
least there yeah and before Boxing Day
you know I'll be giving a few recordings
putting some stuff out there on social
media absolutely
also some people think that I'm not
allowed to see Amanda and things like
that I am the thing is I've got to every
night I've got to sleep in my location
my chosen location because that's
realistic right yeah anyone anyone is
allowed to travel so if my area selected
area is Doncaster it's not like I'm
never allowed to leave Doncaster its I
need to be act as if I'm living in don't
get strong based in Doncaster do you
have any spending money no so how you
know my food on day one I have a week's
against on the walls man if you read the
rules it's like a week's worth of
necessities and essentials clothes food
so after that if you don't make any
money in week one you're screwed yeah
absolutely send me a body on the streets
of Doncaster if I don't make any money
in week one
yeah I'm screwed yeah and then the
documentary will be very disappointing
yeah hopefully with some lessons because
if I fail there is a lesson that it is
okay to player so there'll be lessons
wherever happens yeah now old saying
that failure is not the opposite of
success it's a part of success
absolutely not and some people that
don't succeed because there's a
scheduler
I'm not gonna anything built the feeling
I have right now oh my gosh I'm putting
myself out there I could look stupid I
could fail is the exact same feeling
that thousands of people have about
starting that journey mobs as well
mm-hmm it's like oh I'm gonna tell my
family I tell my parents or I'll gonna
tell my husband
that I'm going to poverty I might look
stupid
I might get laughed at people look at
this if it doesn't work out I might fail
and that's going to be terrible and
that's the same exact feeling that I
have right now yeah and what I'm trying
to do this whole thing is well is
inspire people is I'm trying to take
myself back to what it's like mm-hmm to
start all over again so that I can let
me be in a better position to help
people starting all over again sorry for
the first off it's literally the only
differences between you and someone
who's literally starting out for the
first time it absolutely nothing I mean
nothing
yeah like not many people are in
situation we're in a week's time if they
haven't made money from that property
journey they're gonna be starving yeah
and that's when people say oh wait it's
not realistic cousin because I because I
got a job it's like yeah well then your
advantage in one sense because my
position is if I've just been fired yeah
with no money in the bank yeah yeah I
mean it's a pretty hard situation and I
thought about bringing bringing a man
during that with me but I just thought I
don't think I don't think if things go
bad and you're eating beans on toast or
you're sleeping in your car you can't
really pretty family along well yeah I
just think it's gonna be I think it's
gonna be easy if people to relate to if
he's just me because then they'll always
be aware there was two of you doing this
well there was the audience I just think
you know what let's just start fresh me
foreign place where I don't know super
well done only miles this trying to do
businesses strangers with nothing in the
bank that's it Wow and I can't speak to
Amanda I was saying this as long as I'm
sleeping into the area hopefully it's
something really rethought like Scotland
might be tricky for me to see him handle
at all could maybe hold back because I
gotta sleep in the location but I can
still see Amanda I can still speak to my
friends and stuff but I'm not alone with
Scotland or you know England or could it
be Scotland Isles France well I have
settled me on all the rules
and I said England I can in France no so
yeah this is gonna be this is gonna be
in England yeah I love Scotland up
we would be happy together scholar but
now we are claiming that the rules a bit
different well yeah but is that so I'm
also not allowed to get any of my
friends or staff or anyone to help or
facilitate or participate in the
challenge in any way makes sense yeah so
I can still talk to my kid Ruby I just
can't get them doing stuff for me yeah
but I'll be just go up in them every
night awesome
and ya know me making sure that you
don't shoot yeah I'm gonna making sure I
don't cheat my referee the accountant
will be going to all the figures I don't
know exactly what's gonna happen
I'm a bit afraid but do you think people
want you to succeed or fail I think
people want me to succeed they'll always
be I always said for every one hater
you've helped 200 yeah and in the same
way I imagine I mean man I'd like to
think that people that are watching this
video and people are like Oh Jamie don't
want me to succeed I imagine so well
what about you do you want me to succeed
would you want me to fail I'll see what
he says succeed cheers man well I just
want to inspire people and I just want
to go through it and I want to prove to
myself unto others did as possible yeah
and I've got seen anything done like
this before
if you do fail will you do it again
probably yeah
I'll fail and I'll do it again oh yeah
I'm good with our yeah I'm good with
failure yeah awesome well I think it's
gonna be a really really exciting
challenge oh I'm going to looking
forward to watching it and I'm gonna
come forward to you not being around for
a few weeks now I think it's gonna be
really exciting challenge I'm sure it
will whatever happens inspire lots of
leads so for those people that watching
this video I guess the call to action so
to speak is firstly put the place below
the town or city that you want me to go
to put it below that's going to put into
a hat and we're gonna pull up before the
challenge next I'd love to know you're
just you're just general comments and
thoughts share the video subscribe
follow get down to our Facebook group
property investors with Samuel Leeds I'm
going to be sharing updates while I'm
doing it alive then I can't believe this
is going to be happening so soon and you
I think that's it anything else tomorrow
I just think it's gonna be amazing I'm
really forward to it no ruler I'm gonna
forward to sit watching the documentary
wears out on Boxing Day
great stuff see you soon guys
[Music]